so today I am invite member states to
state the view on the way forward how
can we work on this we would like your
advice as to how to continue because it
is both politically and economically an
important file and in that respect I
hope that we can have short and personal
statements concerning how to move
forward let us remember that whatever
different views there might be maybe we
do always all have shared objectives
first to ensure that the financial
sector makes a fair contribution to the
cost of the crisis and to public
revenues and second to help rebuild
public confidence in this sector and
restore its stability the principles
that we can only make a decision or
regulation if everyone wants a
globalized world that's the same makes
us hopeless in managing the global
economy therefore I think it's maybe the
task of Europe to go ahead in some
regard in the in the convictions that
others will follow if we succeed the
outcomes that we will have no solution
nothing
after years of discussion on financials
like that would be disastrous the
position of German government federal
government is totally clear we are 100%
in favor of support proposals of the
Commission and we were really convinced
that we should do whatever we can to get
a common decision on this is it wise
really to apply such tax in the EU
knowing that the US China Hong Kong
Singapore will not introduce such
attacks is it wise to introduce such
attacks in a limited number of European
countries knowing that the largest
financial centre of Europe ie London
will
introduce Sajit eggs I'm referring to
what George Osborne said in a public
statement in this very group I must say
that I tend to give a negative answer to
those questions because the risk of
financial institutions just choosing to
relocate the activities to a
jurisdiction outside the scope of the
FTT
is probably there or at least I think we
should have more analysis on what the
effect would be of a limited
geographical scope in the application of
such attacks we consider that during the
future technical works sufficient time
should be devoted to a more accurate
evaluation of the economic impact of the
proposal notably of the effects on the
cost of capital for businesses
households and the government sector
certainly we would have a strong
preference for an agreement among all
Member States the argument about the
global scope of this tax being at the
same time certainly a relevant argument
but not a good reason to paralyze
ourselves I believe that some pragmatism
should serve us also here and I believe
that a well advised progress gradual
pragmatic on working on this file would
be welcome and I encourage the
presidency and the Commission to pursue
this line thank you very much to my mind
we we should really try to think about
alternatives here is there any other way
that we could find a solution that that
move us will move us together I would
like to underline that we have a very
strong position on European taxes for us
that is half of the problem we don't
like the financial transaction tax and
we don't like it on a European level and
the reason for that is that it's a long
historical strong political commitment
of the Swedish population that they
believed that they have the right to set
the taxes on themselves and I think for
many countries that at the end of the
day this would also be a major
complication
mosuke occupied no position to vote Gong
Eric opposition Drita post gdb on the
confit era Commission Kabukicho
leadership one Eliquis das that mask it
has a lot of suggestion PO of really
pure logic associate the the pyridine on
his main kayvyun the pope was a
alternative if wily cognitive or Gong
crashes tamale proved impossible the
land back to the people as possible
Elisha to renew a PCC papacy of the
Honda was Mahalo almost at Holly Puente
Veyrons
ad point occur may do mm at the table in
a sweet absurdly Boise the rocket row
shows difficult a cappella girl my vida
more news it will revert romance a
margarite a bacterium oh poor guava
preview BAM when decisions don t value a
personal Dan was shows at least you
Sookie NEPA our independent Policy
Research agency as well as our central
bank also very independent and our
supervision of power but all three have
conducted independent researches and all
three resulted in an alarming negative
result of the financial to sexy text as
it is now on the table and we did not
take a final position on it so it I'm we
are neutral at this point but I have to
deal with those economic points it would
all agree that we need to ensure the
banking sector pays a fair share
towards its costs and pays a fair share
in terms of tax and of course the UK has
introduced a bank levy that raised about
two and a half billion pounds every year
we have a stamp duty which raises two
billion pounds a year as well and we're
very happy for member states to follow
if they choose to do so if there are
issues in the functioning of financial
markets that we need to tackle then we
need to think about the appropriate
regulatory and supervisory tools rather
than assuming attacks will actually
tackle those and deal with those
particular
issues but I just for the record you
point out that our position on this has
remained unchanged Finland supports the
current proposal for a common
transaction tax if it's evident that we
cannot all sign to this proposal we
shouldn't waste too much time in trying
to move the unmovable instead we should
start a process where we try to find a
common ground that would be acceptable
to all 27 member states Austria fully
supports the Commission proposal it is a
huge opinion in the population of all
countries that markets are ruling us and
not we are ruling markets and so I'm in
favor of the argument of Wolfgang we
have to show that we are able to find
solutions and of course I think that it
would be important that if such attacks
were introduced mmm it should not
increase we're not talking about such
attacks funding any increases in EU
budgets we're talking about them
providing a degree of stability and
avoiding the kind of endless haggling
that we unavoidably have to go through
at least once every seven years that's
all I wanted to say so it obviously
needs more work more discussion but the
general principle is not one that we
would be against and in particular the
own resources aspect of it thank you
very much I do understand the message
that at times we send that you know the
crisis came from the banking system so
we need to do something to send the
message against the banking system but
my concern is that like it or not the
banking system is the blood veins of the
world economy and the European economy
and punishing your own blood veins may
cause problems to to your own body
because ultimately we are
intrinsic to it I don't think that the
FTT is really conducive to enhancing
even with the existing impact assessment
I think it's important to take into
account that when translated into annual
figures actually impact on GDP and on
jobs is it's negligible so I think there
is a couple of things that we need to
work on and last but not least to figure
out if there is alternative route to
take